the exact routine that helped me save
six figures in my 20s every single month
I go through this exact process there
are three steps so let's get into it the
first step is updating all of my numbers
this includes my income expenses savings
and investment transfers any debt payoff
and my net worth I track all of this
manually using the personal finance
dashboard the second step in my routine
is self-reflection this is the most
important step you do not want to skip
it because this is where you'll be able
to change your spending Behavior I just
like to evaluate how I've been using my
money how it makes me feel and then
think about any adjustments or changes I
want to make next month the final step
is creating and adjusting my budget for
the next month I like to create an
budget and then every single month I'll
go in there and make adjustments based
on any upcoming plans or travel that I
have this process takes about 25 to 30
minutes per month